This is Cairo.
Egypt’s largest city and its capital.
For decades it's been home to Egyptian rulers
and their palaces.
The Parliament has met in this building
for over 150 years.
And this public square in the heart of Cairo
has been the site of several revolutions.
But in 2015, the Egyptian government
announced the capital would move
about 50 kilometers away...
To this patch of empty desert.
Which is quickly shaping up to be the
New Administrative Capital of Egypt.
This is where a new presidential palace
will go...
the new Parliament building and
a new public square.
Egypt’s government, led by president
Abdel Fattah El-Sisi
claims this new city will solve
a specific problem:
Cairo’s overpopulation.
But the country has a long history of building
new cities to decongest Cairo.
Many of them sit outside the city today.
So, why is Cairo’s population still considered
a ticking time bomb?
And what’s the real reason behind
this new capital?
There's a population counter
outside one of the ministries.
It's mundane, but it also
it's red, flashing lights with these colors
is almost always like telling people...
A little too many of you are here.
This is Mohamed Elshahed
an architectural historian who studies
urban development in Egypt.
And I find this to be quite a dangerous narrative
especially since that's actually not the case.
Egypt's home to more than 100 million people.
And about 20% of them live within the boundaries
of Greater Cairo.
The city has one of the highest
population densities
in the world
with 153,000 people per square kilometer
at its peak.
That’s higher than New York, London, and
Shanghai.
What we know as Cairo, today, was officially
founded on the banks of the Nile
in the 10th century, as the capital of
the Arab Fatimid Caliphate.
The city had to be built near the river
because the rest of the region
was barren desert.
Over the next several centuries, each ruler
built expansions of Cairo
close to the fertile banks.
The Ottomans built these areas...
and the British added these suburbs during
their decades-long occupation of Egypt.
In the 1950s, when the British left and
Egypt became a republic
Cairo was by far the biggest city.
In the 50s, 60s and 70s, millions of impoverished
Egyptians from the countryside
moved to Cairo in search of opportunities
and better living conditions.
But the city that was built haphazardly along
the river
wasn't equipped to house more people.
The city sort of was already kind of
shaped and demarcated
and the green areas around it were left agricultural.
And it's those areas that were cheap
and close enough to those amenities that allowed
then people to step in.
Since the housing that was available
was completely not sufficient.
So farmers started selling small slices of
their agricultural land to the migrants.
A lot of people have to build for themselves
with little money.
So together, so entire families would go vertical
on a small plot of land.
These were the first informal and
technically illegal neighborhoods.
It's informal because it's not, you know,
given licenses for construction.
It's built outside of the economy, that is
the “official economy".
And I think this is actually the result of
the fact that
the economic system really excluded
the majority of the population.
For decades, Egypt's government failed
to build affordable housing
or invest in public services and infrastructure
to support the explosive growth
in Cairo’s density.
And that meant these unplanned and
informal neighborhoods
continued to get more and more crowded
until it became a crisis.
"Egypt’s capital is bursting at the seams."
"Cairo is equipped to handle around 3 million,
in fact,
it's home to 8 million."
"Housing is an area of desperate need."
"Many people in Cairo live in makeshift shacks
in the city's center and in much worse conditions
in the suburbs."
Today, these informal neighborhoods are home
to 60% of Cairo’s population.
Most of them are inhabited by the poor
but many have evolved into middle class neighborhoods.
Collectively, these are the most crowded areas
of Cairo.
And Egypt’s government, under Sisi, points
to them
as the real problem behind Cairo's overcrowding.
I find this to be a very problematic narrative
because then we take a question of
let's say, bad design or bad management from
a state perspective
and turn the blame on actually the people
who are suffering
from the bad design and the bad policies
and say, there's just too many of you.
In fact, the government still considers them
illegal, referring to them as slums.
From the point of view of the state, calling
an area a slum facilitates its removal.
In 2019, the government announced it would
eradicate Cairo's slums by 2030.
Many neighborhoods will be redeveloped
as affluent housing
while thousands of residents will be forcibly
pushed out of their homes
and into affordable housing outside the city.
But instead of focusing on sufficient
affordable housing
they invested billions of dollars in
a whole new city elsewhere.
And it's not the first time an Egyptian ruler
has tried to solve the crisis by starting
fresh in the desert.
"A building boom is in progress."
"New apartment blocks are going up
at a greater rate
since the start of Nasser’s Revolution."
The concept of a new city as a solution for
Cairo's growing population began in the 1950s.
The first attempt was under President
Gamal Abdel Nasser
who ordered the construction of a new city
called Nasr City.
It was also designed to be a new capital
at the time.
There would be space for government buildings,
markets, and a huge new stadium.
But there was a big flaw.
The plan didn't involve affordable housing
for the people in Cairo's most crowded areas.
The need was for a lot of lower class housing.
But that wasn't going to be placed in the
new capital.
Nobody wants to build a shiny new capital
and then fill it with low cost housing.
So it's sort of a trend that already
starts there.
By the 1970s, Egypt had a new leader,
Anwar Sadat
who didn’t end up moving the capitol to
Nasr City.
But he really leaned into the trend of building
‘desert cities’.
Starting in 1976, Egypt’s government built
8 new cities
in the desert around Cairo.
Each time they claimed the goal was
to alleviate overcrowding.
But, most included only expensive housing.
And barely any featured public transportation
making them inaccessible for anyone
without a car.
That’s why today, many of these desert cities
are only partially occupied.
Most who have moved here are Cairo’s
middle and upper class residents.
That means that the majority of the population
that's squeezed in the little green belt
that's now urbanized around the Nile are kind
of X’d-out of these developments.
So we're looking at a condition
that's a result of
I would say, 3 to 4 decades
in particular of
misguided policy that
looks to the outside of the city.
President Sisi is continuing that trend
with his new capital.
These areas are designated for housing, but
mostly
for middle and upper class residents.
Those people are not moving in with handouts.
They're buying their those properties.
And so the main target audience is, again,
a moneyed class.
I think the housing for low-income communities
will be included in the capital
but definitely very limited.
All of this land will be used for
government buildings
and this section will be a business district
featuring this soon-to-be-tallest
building in Africa.
So, if this new capital isn’t really about
solving Cairo’s population density crisis
why is the government so determined
to build it?
In 2011, protests erupted in Egypt
over police brutality.
And they quickly evolved into widespread calls
for the resignation of Egypt’s ruler
of 30 years,
Hosni Mubarak.
Demonstrations took place all over Egypt.
But the biggest were in Cairo.
Specifically, Tahrir Square.
It’s been the epicenter of many political
demonstrations
since the early 20th century.
Largely because it’s so close to Egyptian
government buildings, including the Parliament.
In 2011, millions of people occupied
Tahrir Square for 18 days.
They set up roadblocks...
and battled with police.
On February 11, thousands marched from
Tahrir Square
to the presidential palace, 10 km away
where they ultimately forced Mubarak
to step down.
The ability to control Tahrir Square
and inner Cairo
allowed the protestors to effectively paralyze
the government.
Making their presence and their demands
impossible to ignore.
Sisi remembers that.
He was the head of Egypt’s powerful military
when he seized power in 2013
on the heels of the revolution.
Barely a month after taking power
he commanded his soldiers and police
to crack down
on protestors who opposed him.
The brutal raid killed more than 800 people.
Ever since, he's been systematically trying
to prevent
a revolution that could topple him.
His government has shut down political dissents,
punished journalists, and hindered free speech.
Now, they are redesigning several aspects
of Cairo
to make the city harder to protest in.
They’ve widened dozens of streets
making it more difficult to erect road-blocks.
And they plan to add 40 bridges
which will give the military and police
easier access to the city center.
Sisi’s government has also renovated
Tahrir Square
adding giant monuments and
private security guards
which, some experts, say will make it harder
for large crowds to gather.
Now, they’re taking the final step:
removing the government entirely from Cairo.
Just 7 years after announcing the construction
of the new capital
government officials are starting to move
into these new buildings.
Once that’s complete, all of Egypt’s
political power, including Sisi
will be concentrated here... almost
50 kilometers from Cairo.
And it will all be under heavy guard:
this is the military's sprawling complex nearby.
Even though there is a public square,
called the People’s Piazza
it’s hard to imagine millions of people
making the journey from Cairo
to demonstrate here.
And that may be the point.
The distance, plus the military presence
will allow Sisi to defend his power
in case of an uprising.
So instead of a capital that offers a solution
for the people of Cairo
this city is designed to move the government
out of their reach.